whether you agree with Trump or not it
doesn't really matter for this video
it's much more about what is your big
idea so now how do you apply this to
your business you don't want to be going
around bad-mouthing your competition
they're bad-mouthing your employees or
your former partners I don't think that
ultimately serves you as an entrepreneur
the best learnings actually come from
the people who you disagree with and
when you can learn to learn from people
that you hate that's when the real
growth happens I fundamentally believe
that you can learn from anybody who's
had success and often the best learnings
that you have are from the people you
disagree with or sometimes downright
hate now Donald Trump has said and done
a lot of things that I don't personally
agree with we have the worst immigration
laws in the entire world immediate
construction of a border wall who's
gonna pay for the wall there's not a
Muslim ban but we're totally prepared to
work it out very nicely you see that the
airport you see it all over it's working
out very nicely I'm establishing new
vetting measures to keep radical Islamic
terrorists out of the United States of
America we don't want them here you have
criticized governor Bush for speaking
Spanish on the campaign trail you said
quote he should really set an example by
speaking English in the United States
what's wrong with speaking well I think
it's wonderful and all but I did it a
little bit half-heartedly but I do mean
it to a large extent we have a country
where to assimilate you have to speak
English and I think that where he was
and the way it came out didn't sound
right to me we have to have assimilation
to have a country we have to have a
sibling this is a country where we speak
English not Spanish now I have a good
relationship with Justin Trudeau I
really did other than he had a news
conference that he had because he
assumed I was in an aeroplane and I
wasn't watching
he learned it's gonna cost a lot of
money for the people of Canada he
learned you can't do that you can't do
that now I choose to continue to learn
from Trump because I think a lot of his
strategies are genius even though I
disagree with a good chunk of the way
that he executes them now I'm gonna be
honest if my family was personally
impacted
by any of these policies you know if my
wife was being deported because of a
trump policy I might be a lot harder to
make this video and so I can understand
why a lot of you coming and watching my
OTO dislike this video before even
giving it a chance but I hope that I
would have the courage is still post and
still try to learn from him even if I
was personally impacted so with all that
being said today we're gonna learn about
seven powerful things you can learn from
Donald Trump even if you hate him enjoy
also if you want to hear my thoughts and
the opinions of other thought leaders on
how to have more confidence check out my
series 250 for confidence where every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a 30 second a five-minute video for
free every day to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below around yourself
with greatness if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps that
came before if you're doing work that
you love you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one lead with big ideas as a Canadian
looking at the election from north of
the border one of the things that you
saw Donald Trump what is he staying for
its build the wall build the wall we're
gonna build the wall Mexico is gonna pay
for this wall whether you like the idea
of building a wall or not you knew what
Donald Trump stood for and it was a big
idea Hillary Clinton I could not tell
you what she stood for she was basically
a vote against Trump
and I couldn't pinpoint my finger on
what her big idea was number one are you
ready are you ready
we will build a great wall along the
southern border why don't people ever
tell that side of the school right look
we're gonna have a border it's gonna be
a real border and we're gonna build a
wall and it's going to be a serious wall
and I said we got to build a wall and
everybody said oh that's crazy that's
crazy we will build a wall we will build
a wall we will build a wall the walls
just got ten feet higher they're gonna
pay for the wall and they're gonna enjoy
it okay they're gonna enjoy now this is
a really important lesson for
entrepreneurs if you want to stand out
if you want to win business if you want
people to care about you you have to
stand for something big it has to be
clear what is it your business stands
for if I cannot tell the difference
between you and everybody else then
there's no reason to buy from you
especially as an entrepreneur because
these big companies have traction have
branding have history have marketing
dollars why buy from you instead of some
big company that I already know like and
trust because you staying for a big idea
so what is your big idea I look at my
youtube channel it started really
blowing up once I embraced belief before
that it was just another guy with some
mantra mariel videos now it's all about
belief and not everybody's gonna like it
just like not everybody will like
Trump's wall not everybody likes belief
I think more people like believed in
Trump's wall but not everybody likes
believe and that's okay those people
will self eliminate they won't be a part
of my audiences okay
but the people who want more believe in
their life the people who love my
mission what I stand for that's what my
youtube channel really started to blow
up and so now as I talking about trying
to solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential as I talk about
trying to help a billion people these
big ideas attract people who want to
join me on my mission and so whether you
agree with Trump or not it doesn't
really matter for this video it's much
more about what is your big idea like
who cares about Trump what is your big
idea that you're gonna plant your flag
in the ground and say this is why my
company is here when you come up with
your big idea it's so much easier to
build momentum they get people to rally
behind you to get media attention to get
customers and get suppliers to get
investors but most people don't have a
big idea and they blend and they're
vanilla and so they lose have your big
eye
yeah rule number two is brand your ideas
one of the things that Donald Trump was
so good at especially in the election
was branding people now he did this in a
really negative way he would brand all
of the people who he didn't agree with
and he would name them something and
oftentimes the name stuck they didn't
know a stick but many times the name
stuck because he applied the brain to
them energy guy he gets up and he does a
commercial that so I'm looking at little
Marco and I say man there's something
happening with him and he's like melting
little rocket man rocket fuel for the
America we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea rocket man
is on a suicide mission for himself
we have lyin Ted Cruz I have to be
honest these people that I'm dealing
with are the worst people
well the failing New York Times wrote a
big long front-page story yesterday and
it was very much although we have a
representative in Congress who they say
was here a long time ago they call her
Pocahontas
she's back there little Katie she's back
there that Hillary as I say crooked
Hillary crooked Hillary oh she's just
crooked as they come folks just Accola
crooked Hillary Clinton do we get a get
rid of that crooked woman she's a
crooked one she is a very very dishonest
woman so now how do you apply this to
your business you don't want to be going
around bad-mouthing your competition or
bad-mouthing your employees or your
former partners I don't think that
ultimately serves you as an entrepreneur
but you can take that same strategy and
apply it for the positive the idea is
your branding something so that people
remember it and so if I look at your one
word as an example that's just another
term on self-awareness right
self-awareness is this big nebulous
concept your one word it's an easy
application of it I look at Grant
Cardone he's got the 10x rule the 10x
rule he branded it he named it something
it's easy to remember that all the 10x
rule is is think bigger it's been said
for many many many many years by many
people but grant applied the branding
10x rule that is a lot easier to
remember and so people do you can also
use it in a positive way for the people
on your team as an example I like to
call Alex who works with me at Toronto
dine salsa the general Alex or the
general because he badly wants to be a
leader he came back from a trip in
Mexico one or two years ago dreaming of
being at the front of an army and
leading this army in the battle and
that's how he sees his role at TDS and
so when he's fighting self-confidence
issues or he's not able to you know get
up and and do the thing he needs to do
the hard work the leadership work I
constantly reinforce it he's general
exceda Alex it's the nickname that I
developed for him and so you could take
that idea of branding people and
branding ideas that Trump might use in a
really negative way and use it in a
positive way both for your concepts that
you want to share with the world 10x
rule your one word but also for the
labels that you apply to people so that
they can rise up to meet those
expectations like I do with general Alex
[Music]
rule number three is praise people one
of the things jump is really really
great at is praising people now the
praise may not always be genuine but
when he has somebody who he wants
something from or he wants to
acknowledge somebody who's on his team
he will go out of his way to praise them
to say really great things about them to
lavish them to say it in a public forms
of the media and the people around him
hear about it praising these people in
public again they may not always be
genuine but the strategy of praising
people has really worked out for him
well I think her history is far from
being over I'd like to answer that
question in another 15 years from now I
think she's going to go down at a
minimum as a great senator I think she
is a great wife to a president and I
think Bill Clinton was a great president
you know you look at the country then
the economy was doing great look at what
happened during the Clinton years I mean
we had no war the economy was doing
great everybody was happy a lot of
people hated him because of a jealous as
hell you know people get jealous and
they hate you people don't like him
because they're jealous of but Bill
Clinton was a great president I mean I
hope we can be so lucky in terms of the
economy and in terms of other aspects I
mean we weren't in wars with tuna I'm
not blaming Afghanistan by the way is
probably a place that we should be Iraq
we shouldn't be a bill clot was a great
president Hillary Clinton is a great
woman and a good woman oh you said of
Hillary Clinton that she was quote
pretty badly abused during her
presidential campaign why say that I
thought that they roughed her up pretty
good I I think she's a wonderful woman I
think that she's a little bit
misunderstood you know Hillary's a very
smart woman very tough woman that's fine
she's also a very nice person and I know
Hillary and I know her husband very well
they're fine people I thought and you
know part of that is a rough political
battle I thought she was roughed up I
thought she and I'm not knocking the
other side you know you want to win a
battle so if it gets a little bit nasty
it is politics and politics is a tough
game but I thought she was perhaps
unnecessarily roughed up she took some
pretty hard hits
I respect the
fact that director Comey was able to
come back after what he did and it took
guts for director Comey to make the move
that he made in light of the kind of
opposition he had where they're trying
to protect her from criminal prosecution
you know that good job by the FBI have
respect that the FBI has given it a
second chance the FBI and I give them a
lot of credit because they're fighting
forces that they're not supposed to be
fighting there's little doubt that FBI
director Comey and the great special
agents of the FBI will be able to
collect more than enough evidence to
garner indictments against Hillary
Clinton become more famous than me when
you praise people they feel good
especially when you praise them in
public and so again
Trump's clips may not have always been
the most genuine praise of people that
he actually likes but he knows how to
use praise to manipulate people which
you can use for yourself to manipulate
them in a positive way not just for your
own selfish interest but in a way that
serves everybody serves you serves them
serves the community serves the mission
that they are on so as an example when I
look at the people on my team if I'm
talking about Alex I'm talking about
lily and talking about anybody who works
with me or for me in public it's always
positive it's always big praise it's
always talking about how great they are
and and all of that praise for me is
genuine for all the people on my team I
can find amazing qualities amazing
things that I want to recognize and I
did this workshop in May and I had Lily
and I had J rise and I had Alex do some
guest presentations the front and in the
setup to it I'd always be singing their
praises and a lot of times you know
things that they don't hear that often
because in private I'm really hard on
people in private Alex Lily they feel
the Bern
because I know ultimately what they want
to accomplish and I'm part of my role is
helping push the
to go and get that thing they want the
push they like the push they look
forward to the push they want to hang
around me more to get the push
so I'm private it's always really hard
but in public it's always praised it's
always making them look good it's always
trying to keep that on to them and so I
think it's a great strategy to pull in
for your business to publicly praise the
people on your team your customers your
suppliers your investors the people who
are involved in your business your
family even if in private you're pushing
them hard and you may not always be
positive giving them public praise
giving them some feeling of recognition
can go a long way to helping build the
loyalty build the strength and making
them feel worthy to go off and do this
bigger mission rule number four is be
the Challenger I think one of the things
that Donald Trump has really done well
is established himself as a challenger
brand even though he is a super-rich guy
he's had a billion dollars or however
much he has in his bank account and you
would see him as somebody that people
can't look up to because he's so far
removed from the common person it's
funny how so many people relate to him
because he positions himself as the
outsider he is a challenger he is
against the norm he is not the typical
politician and he uses that challenger
brand to build up a mass following of
people who want to go and bolt and
support him only against the tide is
great if it works now it doesn't always
work and you really have to be smart to
go against the tide because you're going
against a lot of smart people but when
you get it right you'll end up better
weathers Microsoft or Google I mean so
many people that have really hit big
have gone against the tide but you have
to have great confidence in yourself you
have to be the right person there are
very few people that can pull it off but
when you pull it off it's great
same thing in real estate you go against
the tide people are selling you're
buying the tide changes these
politicians such liars liars our
Republican system is absolutely rigged
they're fed up with the stupidity in
Washington I went to an Ivy League
school
I'm very highly educated I know words I
had the best words I have the
but there's no better word than stupid
my hands look at these hands lyin Ted
and little Marco yeah and if there's a
group out there just throw him the hell
out that's okay he's a man of resentment
and his voters have resentment and those
resentments somehow connected with each
other during the campaign Hillary
Clinton proved the perfect foil a person
who spent most of her adult life in
politics who surrounded herself with
Democratic establishment elites and who
in the end took the role of Nemesis
leading to the trumpian rallying cry in
the end Trump trialed first followers
that's a major cause for celebration
for his critics including those within
his own party a time of serious
retrenchment for America Donald Trump
becoming president elect Trump is a
watershed moment I think adopting this
challenger brand can really help you as
an entrepreneur as well because that's
what we are that's what entrepreneurs
are we are we are strange ducks we are
the outsider we were the outcasts were
the ones trying to change the way things
are done in an industry we want to make
our dent in the universe right we want
to have a big impact and we're going up
against big companies whatever industry
you're in there's a big established
player they have billions of dollars
they have a big customer base they've
been around for many many many years and
so who are you to go up against these
people and I think one of the biggest
mistakes entrepreneurs make is you try
to look like these big competitions you
try to look like a big player you have a
really professional website you have
really professional pictures and it's
not to say don't be professional but
you're losing your authenticity the
thing that you're gonna win on is your
story is your heart is your passion is
what you want to do to make this
industry better that has to come out
that challenge your brand that feeling
that you care that you understand the
customer is better than these big
companies who just treat them like a
number that story is really really
important and so I think the starting
point is gonna be your bell Page going
there making it passionate tell me why
you did this business ideally you can
make a video telling me your story you
can keep making more and more videos I
want to see the heart
want to see the care I want to feel like
you're with me I will buy from you if I
feel like you're with me and you're
going up against these giant
corporations they don't care about me
so establishing that challenger brand I
think is something that every
entrepreneur can and should be able to
do and it's an easy way to bring in a
lot more business for yourself rule
number five has used the media Donald
Trump gets so much publicity for free
every single day from the media because
he knows how to stay current he knows
how to stay top of mind even if for the
wrong reason sometimes even it's her
reasons that you may not agree with you
can admire the fact that he is always in
the media and this is not just something
that he discovered through Twitter and
now that he's the president he can say a
bunch of things and get tons of media
this has always been a big part of his
strategy in building his personal brand
do you have the the genes to be a
successful politician well you never
really know I think I'm pretty outspoken
and that's not probably a good thing in
terms of a politician but it's a good
thing if you ever got elected you can
really do a job I believe that perhaps
I'm portrayed differently than I I
actually am I believe I'm portrayed in a
rougher sense than the actual product
and I hope that's true
because I hope the actual product is a
lot more mellow than the portrayal and
that may be his biggest asset of all
when people attack Trump they reinforce
the version of Trump that Trump wants
people to see and inevitably that keeps
Trump's name in the news this is a great
strategy that you can use as an
entrepreneur and again you take the
strategy that he's using and change up
the execution if you don't like how
antagonistic he might be at times then
you don't need to model that but the
idea is you need to find ways to stay
relevant constantly and so this is
something I see don't do a great job of
looking at the news cycle looking at
what is trending right now and what is
your perspective a friend of mine Jeremy
vest called me out recently and said
Evan it's it's your moral obligation to
spread believe through current events
and it hit me it hit me hard because
I've always been like I'm a I'm not a
trending articles kind of guy I'm not a
trending content kind of guy I like
doing the evergreen stuff
that will last forever but he said look
at the news cycle look at how negative
it is right now look at all the all the
contention of the hatred that's happened
in a new cycle it's your moral
responsibility to inject some believe
into it I'm still figuring out my
strategy to do that effectively but he's
right it's true I should and you can too
whatever you stand for whatever your
mission is looking at what is trending
right now and figuring how can I inject
my core value into this discussion how
can I take this thing that's really
negative and turn it positive and spin
it in a way that makes sense for people
through your one word through your lens
through what you care about so for
example if you hate Donald Trump and
your heinous policies instead of just
complaining about it to your friends to
your community making making attacking
hate videos instead of just doing that
that doesn't really serve anything
except spur up more hatred more
negativity what's your solution how do
you solve this problem for me what's the
believed way to handle this situation
what's the believed way to handle this
crisis what would I do in that situation
what would you do nobody wants to listen
to complainers except the other people
who are also complaining it doesn't
solve anything but understanding what
you staying for understanding what your
core value is and then using that as the
lens to comment on trending news is an
easy way to stay top of mind to stay
front-and-center here's another quick
way to do it look on Twitter go to the
homepage on the left side down the sides
is always going to be these trending
conversations you may not be able to
contribute to every single trending
conversation but the ones that are have
your two cents have your say add to the
conversation say something meaningful
don't just give it a fist bump or a
heart or sad emoji give your two cents
on it be a thought leader that's what
you are here to be as an entrepreneur
you are a thought leader you were an
industry shaker you're not just someone
who's gonna go with the flow and then
just complain quietly to your friends
when it doesn't go your way so look down
that side on Twitter see out of the 10
ones that are trending what you can add
your own two cents on and then do that
and make it a practice I do that every
day as part of the windows that I open
on a daily basis the Twitter homepage is
one of them and I always look at what
the training comment
stations are and I too need to do a
better job of speaking out on the issues
that are out there right now which is
even with this video it's it's an
attempt at it Donald Trump's in the news
a lot there's a lot of negative and
hatred around it and if you feel that
way awesome there's a lot of points that
he's doing that I don't agree with but I
still choose to learn from him this is
me injecting believed into the news
cycle because I think even if you hate
Trump there's a lot that you can learn
from him rule number six is be stubborn
one of the things that just keeps coming
up over and over and over again is how
stubborn and chump is and if he gets
caught in something instead of reversing
and apologizing or going the other way
he just doubles down and he becomes more
stubborn and more stubborn and more
stubborn about the issue if we're unable
to make a deal will terminate NAFTA will
have a better deal if we are unable to
make a deal we will be a better off
right now we are not going to live with
the deals the way they are European
Union treats us very unfairly Canada
very unfairly Mexico very unfilled you
know he's been very stubborn on NAFTA
very stubborn on the wall and very
stubborn with the relationship with
Mexico
[Music]
I didn't say that I said I've been
preparing all my life I always believed
in preparation but I've been preparing
all my life you know these one-week
preparations they don't work just ask
Hilary what happened to her in the
debate so I've been preparing for this
all my life and frankly it's really just
the fake news because if you run Peter
just a little bit longer than clip you
would see I've really been preparing all
my life I said that but of court you
know the news doesn't pick that up
because it's fake dude and why I think
this is really point for entrepreneurs
is the most successful entrepreneurs are
the ones who are really really stubborn
about the mission you're stubborn about
the why you're stubborn about what it is
that you're trying to accomplish but the
best entrepreneurs are really flexible
about the how you almost don't care how
it happens as long as within ethical
guidelines you're flexible in the how
and listen to how it will change many
many many many many times but the Y is
constant and so in looking at at my
mission I want to help a billion people
I want to solve the world's biggest
problems right now YouTube I think is
one of the best ways to do it I think
it's one of the easiest ways to reach
mass audience to have a message that
lives forever
that gets hundreds of millions of views
and be able to have an impact that's why
I'm playing here if something came along
though that had a bigger impact in
YouTube I would start experimenting with
that I might jump ship over to that I'm
playing a lot with Instagram them I'm
tasting I'm testing the waters I'm
seeing if that becomes a better platform
I might spend less time on YouTube or
one day I will have to totally abandon
YouTube and go somewhere else because it
ultimately accused my mission or I think
a lot of people fall down is they get
attached to the how and often forget the
why the hell does not matter as long as
again within ethical boundaries so how
does not matter you are chasing the why
you are chasing a mission that should be
your primary focus and one of the
reasons why people love Trump so much is
because they see him as somebody who is
really mission driven now you may not
you may not agree with the mission that
may not be what you're all about but the
people who love the mission they are all
in on him and when he doubles down on it
and when he's really stubborn about his
mission people love it even more
when you are a leader and you have a why
here's why we are here this is what I
believe I believe in believe and then if
the next day I reverse it and the next
day I come back and next day I reverse
it again
not the how but the why what we're
trying to accomplish if that wavers
constantly then you won't have people
under you then you want people who
follow the mission because they don't
know what the mission is anymore because
now you've become vanilla and so it
leads to a lot of people hating Trump
because of how stubborn he is and and
what he stains for and if you hate his
mission you will just hate him even more
more and more but for the entrepreneurs
who are on a mission you don't care
about the haters you care about the
people who are with you in this battle
and Trump does a really good job of
keeping his loyal people motivated on
board because he is really stubborn
about accomplishing the things that he
wants to accomplish and rule number
seven is follow your instincts this is
one thing that Trump tends to do a lot
of he doesn't listen to his advisers he
doesn't listen to the people around him
he likes to listen to his gut he likes
to follow his instincts and it's one of
the pieces of advice that he loves
giving the most other people too
sometimes in life to be successful
oftentimes most of the time you have to
follow your instincts you have to follow
your gut you have to your parents may
say wrong your whoever may say wrong but
you have to do it and I think ultimately
as an entrepreneur you need to learn to
listen to your gut I think you can use
advisors you can use it people around
you as a counselor but not a jailer you
want to use the opinions that hopefully
help you make a better decision but not
be worried about their judgment or their
treatment of you or how they're gonna
act or think if you go off and do this
thing where I think so many people
prevent themselves from becoming great
entrepreneurs that end up in a job that
they hate because they're trying to
please their parents because they're
afraid of the judgment that they would
get from their friends and their
community if they tried this business
and it didn't work I see it so often
from you guys in my youtube comments or
my Instagram comments and people that I
meet at different events they have a
dream you have a dream you want to
accomplish something you want to go and
do this you have this gut instinct you
this feelin this thing is gonna be great
for you but you're just too afraid to go
off and do it because of the judgement
of the people around you and so learning
is something you can learn from Trump
learning to let go of the opinions of
other people on what you're doing and go
and do you and learn to understand what
that means and learn to understand how
to listen to your gut and what that
looks like and then go off and do it
regardless of what the people around you
think is a skill that you can develop
and learn for yourself so those are the
seven powerful things I think you can
learn from Donald Trump even if you hate
him and again I want to reiterate I
think the best learnings that you can
have are often from the people who you
don't agree with I think if you only
want to learn from somebody who fits
inside this perfect little box then you
haven't done anything except box
yourself in and if you can learn to
learn from people who you hate just like
if you can learn to learn from your
haters for example if somebody is
yelling at you and telling you that you
suck and telling you all of these
negative things about you but in there
is a kernel of truth that you can learn
to help you get better
amazing take it but if you can only take
feedback if somebody sugarcoats
everything for you and says you know
before we get started I just I want to
tell you how much I love you and how
much you mean to me and it has to be
packaged into this nice little box
before you listen to the feedback the
only person you are hurting is yourself
because you choose to only learn from
one certain style and I think it's the
same thing for for white people who only
want learn from white people and black
people who only want to learn from black
people and authors who only want learn
from other authors the best learning
that you will get is yes some people who
look like you and are in your industry
but I think the best learnings actually
come from the people who you disagree
with and when you can learn to learn
from people that you hate that's when
the real growth happens so I did my
seven rules today my challenge is for
the Trump haters to find 1/8 to find one
other thing that you can learn from him
that can make you better as a human
being and for the Trump lovers to find
somewhere that you hate let's say Obama
what's one thing about Obama that if you
hate Obama what's one thing that you can
learn from
him that can make your life or your
business better let's learn to build
some bridges guys and not tear them down
and I think that comes from learning to
respect the people and their strategies
and their genius people have had success
even if you hate them and totally
disagree with them let me know leaving
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video